and perfectionism here it is it
generally stops you more than it more
than it helps you it stops you from
starting projects cuz you're not ready
it stops you from starting relationships
you know like like oh if I lose 10 more
pounds or if I if I pay off my college
debt then it's and it stops you from
finishing anything because because it's
not ready
James is an author an artist a designer
and a professional Hellraiser his own
description there he's taught for many
many years he's also a writer he's
written two books a third one on the way
motivational speaker a creative coach
and his work is included in permanent
collections of museums worldwide now
I've known James's work longer than I've
known who he is
that's how pervasive his work is how
powerful it is I've seen his images
everywhere and now that I'm going
through his book I'm like wow James
you've you've been a busy person you've
been a busy human being I want to just
bring up some of your work and these ten
rules that I found on the Internet
luckily we confirm that they are yours
indeed the first rule is learn the rules
and then break them now rules are great
rules keep us from chaos right mm-hmm
but even the innocuous rules like like
like don't rock the boat or be nice you
know if they get in the way in if they
if they if they if they impede your
creativity you know then then then the
hell with them then find other ways
around them so and what I mean
particularly men obviously they're Chris
was like you know the kerning and all
the kind of anal retentive stuff that
diner designers love getting their
panties in a wad about um but but those
those concerns don't mean anything to
real people real people want real human
contact you want to see that that life
happens and it's okay yeah so yeah and
so so so so rules are great for some
people but you know when they when they
when they get in the way of you creating
and you making money then you need to
kindly disregard them let's get the
point number two here don't decorate
crap no one cares what your type looks
like if your words are not worth reading
damn poetry
people are interested in poetry people
aren't you know people the thing the way
the reason I made that is it was a
period of like a renaissance in
typography where you know all this new
software was coming into play where you
could really you could do a sketch you
just Canidae and then you can start
working on these vectors and make all
this perfect and what that what what
that software has done is made all
typography look alike mmm it all looks
alike I see it on Instagram you know
looks like doesn't matter if it's on a
[ __ ] chalkboard or if it's a book
cover or what the hall
so I'm much more concerned about what
the words say than what they look like
and that's why my words are kind of
clumsy that's why I don't really care
about beautiful or ugly there are no
ugly typefaces there are only ugly
designer what does that really mean what
are you trying to say designers I mean
close-minded I mean designers who are
like oh I would never use that typeface
you know it's like it's like when I was
a kid I remember like when I was a kid
when I was my 20s I remember you go that
you go out to dinner with with designers
and they start picking up they start
picking on the menu like really is that
happens all the time yeah would you
believe they used this typeface on the
menu oh my god I'm like chef right like
he cares who cares do you want the
chicken or you want the fish number four
there is no right font you are a
magician make your own what I try to do
and I learned this from from one of my
one of my heroes and one of my teachers
and one of my friends as an old French
designer named pierre bernard and they
he had a studio called got booze and
they did a lot of hand there was a lot
of hand lettering in their stuff and i
was talking with him once and I said do
you you know do you do you write this
word like 17 times and then cut him up
with scissors and put them back together
and he said no we write it maybe maybe
two or three times but we always choose
the first oh and I thought oh that's
awesome and that's what this is about
because what I learned in if in my
career is I spend so much time again
judging judging my work looking at it
going now this should be a little longer
or maybe that could and I'm like you
know what nobody cares nobody cares just
just just get be done and be happy yeah
and and and let that life live in it so
I go back and fix anything
well I all right all right well you know
when things get scanned in they don't
even get cleaned up you know if there's
like a little extra doodle on the page
like looks awesome to me
because that's life and I you know I'm
just trying to be as authentic and quite
frankly if you want to get deep as
vulnerable as possible rule number five
sometimes the wrongest type choice is
the best type choice yeah yeah I learned
that a bunch of years ago working on one
particular job where I had been working
as a book jacket signer when I first got
when I first left art school I was
working as a book jack designer for a
publishing company and I was it was all
these like like a book about the second
world war so you'd have to have like a
stencil type and you can rough it up
right you know you're like going for
those cliches and then I learned oh wait
a second if I use that roughed up
stencil type and I put it on the the
young adults love novel it's much more
interesting more if I use the hallmark
the hallmark cursive typography for this
for for this book about death and dying
in the Second World War
wait a minute you know like so this idea
of like we're always searching for the
right typeface but there is none really
and sometimes the wrong is and for me as
a teacher and as especially if you were
talking about visuals and and and
cliches and ideas the wrong ggest idea
is always the best idea avoid any tricks
available from a pulldown menu I might
only want to go there it sounds so
pedestrian if I go there so let's just
move to the next one
it seems up it seems kind of obvious
point number seven is that technology is
not the answer you are the answer it's
inside of you you've already said it and
I think we can now move on to point
number eight which is avoid trends
create your own style and stop following
the herd yeah you know I think we talked
about this in a couple of different ways
yes you know if you're following the
herd the the view never changes right
just by every every every leader in in
any industry at one point was
was laughed at right right at one point
had no audience had no like you know it
came up today in the creative morning
things this gal said hey I've got this
new purpose and I've been working on it
for years she said I don't you know
she's like I don't have the audience for
it now and I don't know you know my
friends don't believe and believe in it
and I'm like you know you sound like a
lot of it like you sound like a bunch of
those correct those crazy people who
started working in their garage making
computers the birth there it is number
nine the birth of fake perfection I love
this I love it began here as a rule and
then it became a whole book yes yes hmm
I wrote a few more words than two and
perfectionism here it is profession is
is is interesting in that it generally
stops you more than it more than it
helps you right it stops you from
starting projects because you're not
ready it stops you from starting
relationships you know like like oh if I
lose ten more pounds or if I if I pay
off my college debt then right it's and
it stops you from finishing anything
because because it's not ready
you know I'd CIT students you know
they'd come out of school you know four
or five years out of school and they'd
come see me and in the studio and I'm
like hey what are you doing they're like
well I'm working on my portfolio I'm
like god it's done mm-hmm this go but
but they had this perfectionism thing
that stops them from you know or or or
the per other perfectionism thing is
like the people who have by their bed
stand have a million self-help books
that they've read all of them they've
read the burn a brown and they've read
all this stuff and they're like and they
and and and they're still in the same
situation because what they're doing is
they're using that you know
procrastination and perfection together
to not do anything do not act to move
forward right here's his rule ten we've
already talked about this following the
rules makes your work look like everyone
else's totally totally and this goes a
Chris's across the board and this is
fashion this is food is everything yes
you know in in in in in in in this book
in the new book in fact there's this
thing about
and I and I and I'd love your take on
this um there's this thing about the in
in every job in every act of creation
there's the objective and this the
subjective and the objective is to
satisfy the client to fulfill the
request or the proposal right just you
know to make the to em and for example a
chef needs to make food that is good and
hot
then there's the subjective part and the
subjective is the stuff we're never
given this stuff is this we're never
asked for the subjective is how you
fulfill through through a sense of humor
a sense of sexuality a sense of the
macabre
right so a chef could not only give you
food that is hot and good they can
create an entire experience they can
create a memory
what is the best way to find my voice ah
I love that question I get that all the
time I love that question
okay whoever whoever sent it in whatever
17 people sent that in it's not hiding
so stop using that vocabulary I've got
to find it it's not hiding and and it's
not out there someplace you got to read
that book and do that thing and take
this Skillshare class and it's none of
that it's harder than that
and though maybe it's harder than that
because you need you need to allow it
you need to allow it you have an opinion
you have something to say and it's all
comes from it comes from it's it's
because of and in spite of your parents
it's all of your background it's your
history it's the places you've traveled
it's the things that made you weird as a
kid that make you great today but that's
allowing that and by saying that it
sounds easy but what that means is now I
need to be vulnerable now I need to be
authentic and dare I say something that
somebody may not like because we're live
we live in fear of that but that's the
process and that doesn't for today's
video thanks for watching everyone if
you want to check out the full live
stream you can watch it right there and
we will see you on the next video Brewed
okay